hablemos de este partido entre el Real
Madrid y el Fútbol Club Barcelona sería
este el golpe que necesitaba Xavi
Hernández sus dirigidos para sentenciar
la liga yo quería Luis Yo estoy de
acuerdo en que este partido Más allá de
los futbolístico vimos en Barcelona una
respuesta emocional que es fundamental
para que un campeón pueda lograr ese
objetivo yo creo que futbolísticamente
estamos viendo un equipo que sabe
presionar muy bien un equipo que ha
logrado presionar alto y que si bien a
lo largo de esta temporada o de este
tiempo que ha estado Chávez frente al
equipo se le ha cuestionado muchísimo Si
este es el estilo original o sí o muy
metódico de este Barcelona creo que ha
logrado tener una respuesta muy
interesantes A eso se le suma un Frankie
de young que creo que ha sido
fundamental fundamental en esta este
rearmado de este Barcelona creo que ya
había entendió que tenía que adaptarse
un poco más a los recursos y este y esto
es un poco digamos el desenlace de ello
ha dicho que siendo un equipo que por
supuesto le hace muy difícil a todos sus
rivales digamos quedarse con las
victorias vemos un vinicius que sin duda
sigue siendo un jugador muy relevante y
e independientemente de que busquets hoy
no estuvo en su mejor partido creo que
estos estos otros tres volantes porque
sumo a Gaby digamos en esta posición le
han dado a Barcelona una estabilidad que
es bastante interesante Entonces sí creo
que este Barcelona
sacándole 12 puntos al Real Madrid con
doce fechas de distancia creo que podría
determinarse como el Virtual campeón de
esta liga española vamos a seguir
hablando del Real Madrid pero en este
caso hablamos de la Liga de Campeones o
la Champions League que el pasado día
viernes
celebró el sorteo de los cuartos de
final el Madrid va a enfrentarse al
Chelsea un nuevo equipo inglés le tiene
ancelotti la medida los equipos ingleses
en este torneo yo creo que cuando uno
habla de ancelotti Real Madrid en
Champions se abre como todo una nueva
ventana
tenemos un equipo muy sólido ante el
Liverpool y sabemos lo que representa en
cuanto a esa jerarquía que es un
imponderable del fútbol no se puede
medir pero sí se percibe cuando es un
equipo como este sale a la cancha
Chelsea todavía no ha logrado yo creo
que engranar totalmente el juego Aunque
tiene figuras
destacadísimas no el ingreso de benzo
Fernández pero se vería como un proyecto
más a futuro esto es Champions y por eso
nos encanta verla y todo puede pasar
nadie se imaginaba que Real Madrid
pudiese superar digamos por esa
distancia Liverpool en este partido de
ida pero yo creo que este Real Madrid
sigue siendo y ahora no teniendo la
presión de la liga yo creo que se va a
enfocar aún más en esta Champions Así
que sigue siendo el favorito por lo
menos en esa llave a pesar de que es el
único Club español que está en la liga
también se viene una nueva ficha una
nueva fecha FIFA en los próximos días Y
quería aprovechar Sara para conversar
contigo qué podemos esperar de las
elecciones sudamericanas que estarán
muchas de ellas procesos de cara bien
sea la Copa del 2024 o ya a la copa del
mundo del año 2026 Bueno lo primero es
que vemos un campeón del mundo una
Argentina que va a seguir celebrando con
su afición en Argentina eligió dos
partidos amistosos para este comienzo de
año ante Panamá y Curazao lo que lo que
hace presentir que de lo que se trata es
de darle un poco más de rodaje a sus
jugadores estos que fueron campeones del
mundo me parece importante ver que Cuál
es la decisión que va a tomar Brasil va
este amistoso frente a Marruecos una de
las grandes revelaciones de este mundial
queremos volver a ver este tipo de
regraga y que nos encantó a todos por
esa solidez por ese espíritu competitivo
que tuvo durante el Mundial y para ahora
se va con Ramón Meneses que es el
técnico campeón sub-20 llega a dirigir
este partido y lo mismo va a ser Uruguay
también con Marcelo Broly que era el
técnico de la sub-20 que va a dirigir
este partido que ellos van a tener
también frente a Corea del Sur
Diego Alonso se viene aún no está
totalmente desestimado de la selección
uruguaya se le va a dar un tiempo de
espera porque un poco la federación si
viene el presidente si Confía en la
federación no Uruguay tiene este proceso
de recambio muy importante lo de Diego
Alonso sin duda quedó en deuda y se
enfrenta un Corea del Sur que yo creo
que tanto para para Uruguay como para
Colombia va a ser un rival muy
interesante si bien Quedó eliminado ante
Brasil en el mundial yo creo que vimos
un equipo que unos equipos asiáticos que
más allá de esos lugares comunes de que
son equipos veloces de que son equipos
ordenados prácticamente ya tienen
jugadores e individualidades que también
ponen mucha resistencia y creo que son
una buena medida para este inicio de
temporada hablando de esto pues ya
finalmente la conmebol definió que la
eliminatoria empezará en septiembre con
tres flechas FIFA es decir seis partidos
este año Así que ya queda poco tiempo
para que estos equipos terminen de
afinar un reto duro para Perú con Juan
Reynoso al frente
eligió a Alemania y a Marruecos también
yo creo que son dos equipos que van a
medir muchísimo un equipo que trae una
selección que convocó a sus grandes
figuras digamos galesa en el arco un
poco su estructura base pero que también
empieza a tener esas necesidad de traer
nuevos jugadores para esta eliminatoria
con miras a lo que va a ser México y
Estados Unidos 2026 Muchísimas gracias
Sara por ofrecernos este amplio análisis
respecto al balón internacional